[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport mit Fußball der
Männer und der Frauen schönen guten
Abend von mir wir haben unter anderem
diese Themen für Sie
Diskussion bis zum letzten Tag in
Deutschland gehen morgen die letzten
Atomkraftwerke vom Netz Europa ist in
der Frage gespalten
Mahnung an China Außenministerin
baerbock verlangt bei ihrem Besuch das
Peking auf russlands Präsident Putin
einwirkt
und auf zum Jupiter die ESA Raumsonde
juice ist unterwegs zum größten Planeten
des Sonnensystems
[Musik]
auf den letzten Metern vor dem
endgültigen Atomausstieg Kochen Ängste
und Diskussionen noch mal hoch werden
die Preise steigen wenn in Deutschland
kein Atomkraftwerk mehr Strom liefert
wird es genug Energie geben werden wir
die Klimaziele erreichen können
CDU-Chef Merz spricht von einem
schwarzen Tag für Deutschland morgen
denn dann gehen die letzten drei
Atomkraftwerke vom Netz dieser zwei in
Bayern Neckarwestheim zwei in
Baden-Württemberg und Emsland in
Niedersachsen ihr Anteil an der
Stromversorgung im ersten Quartal dieses
Jahres
4,5%. wenn dort morgen die Stecker
gezogen sind dauert es noch Jahrzehnte
bis die Atomanlagen endgültig
zurückgebaut sein werden das wohnsack
es sind die letzten Betriebsstunden der
Meiler Neckarwestheim Isa 2 und Emsland
morgen soll nach mehr als 60 Jahren
endgültig Schluss sein mit der
Stromgewinnung aus Kernenergie in
Deutschland der Atomausstieg ist seit
über zehn Jahren fest beschlossene Sache
im übrigen auch mit CDU und FDP wir
haben uns darauf vorbereitet wir müssten
mit den Erneuerbaren weiter sein
deswegen haben wir beispielsweise noch
Kohle und Gas aber Atomkraft ist alles
andere als zukunftsfähig und insofern
ist das ein guter Tag doch von der Union
kommt heute scharfe Kritik vor allem am
Zeitpunkt der Abschaltung die
Versorgungssicherheit sei gefährdet
der Ausstieg bleibt richtig aber der
Zeitpunkt ist falsch wir haben
Energiekrise in wir haben eine klimale
Lücke und dann Kernenergie abzustellen
anstatt dessen auf Braunkohle auf
Steinkohle zu setzen das schadet im
Klima und es schwächte Energiesicherheit
wir werden nicht als Industrieland
bestehen können wenn Energie nicht
preiswert zur Verfügung steht wenn
Energie ein knappes Gut wird es ist eine
wirklich falsche Entscheidung Kritik
kommt allerdings auch weiter von der FDP
ihr Streit mit den Grünen zwang den
Bundeskanzler bereits Ende letzten
Jahres seine Richtlinienkompetenz
anzuwenden und die Abschaltung um
dreieinhalb Monate zu verschieben in der
aktuellen Situation wäre es sehr klug
die Kernkraftwerke mindestens in einer
Reserve zu halten es ist kein Geheimnis
wenn wir Freien Demokraten in der
Bundesregierung alleine wären dann
würden wir die Kernkraftwerke jetzt
nicht ausschalten von der Linkspartei
dagegen kommt grundsätzliche Zustimmung
verbunden aber mit der Warnung vor hören
Strompreisen es geht tatsächlich jetzt
zu verhindern dass die Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher vor allem die Menschen
mit geringen und mittleren Einkommen vor
erhöhte Preise gestellt werden das heißt
hier muss der Staat gegensteuern meiner
Ansicht nach brauche es direkt
Unterstützung für Haushalte mit
niedrigen und mittleren Einkommen mit
der Abschaltung der letzten drei Meiler
wird die Kernenergie in Deutschland
Geschichte sein die politische
Diskussion allerdings wird wohl
weitergehen
nicht nur in Deutschland mit dem
Abschied von der Atomkraft steht
Deutschland in Europa ziemlich allein da
zwar haben Belgien Spanien und die
Schweiz den Ausstieg angekündigt
vollzogen ist er aber noch lange nicht
eine Geländer bauen sogar neue Anlagen
trotz der enormen Kosten und den Fragen
rund um Sicherheit und Endlagerung
Andreas Linke hat mehr
am Karlsruher Institut für Technologie
forschen Sie weiterhin an nuklearer
Sicherheit es geht aktuell um das
langfristige Wärmeverhalten von
Brennelementen im Zwischenlage wo sie
vielleicht 60 Jahre länger bleiben
werden als zunächst geplant generell
beurteilen Sie hier die Atomkraft als
beherrschbare Technik auch wenn der
Ausstieg kein Fehler sein wir haben
jetzt ja natürlich den Druck der
Erneuerbaren möglichst schnell weiter zu
entwickeln Speichertechnologien zu
entwickeln andere Länder wie in
Frankreich Finnland auch Tschechien
betreiben Kernkraftwerke weiter und
insgesamt in Europa könnte damit
vielleicht ja sogar sehr sehr CO2 Arme
Energie Mix entstehen
in Frankreich soll kommendes Jahr der
dritte Block des AKW flommern Wiehl in
Betrieb gehen nicht so weit ist das
britische Atomkraftwerk hinklypoint bei
beiden verlängerte sich die Bauzeit weit
über 10 Jahre bei vervielfachten Kosten
Atomkraft ist teuer hingli point kostet
umgerechnet mehr als 30 Milliarden Euro
im Großbritannien sehen wir den Fall
dass die britische Regierung dem
zukünftigen Betreiber des Kernkraftwerks
sehr hohe stromabnahmepreise für die
nächsten 30 Jahre garantieren muss damit
eben Unternehmen bereit sind
Atomkraftwerke zu bauen
mit 14 Jahren Verspätung geht der
finnische Reaktor in ulcino uto diese
Tage in Betrieb in den Nachbarschaft
entsteht das Atome entlager Finlands
infinit 50m Tiefe am Ende landen die
Brennelemente in solchen Hohlräumen bin
in zwei Jahren soll ein Probebetrieb
beginnen in der Frage des Endlagers sind
fast alle anderen Atom Nationen hinten
dran Deutschland sucht noch den Standort
mit dem Für und Wieder des Atomausstiegs
beschäftigt sich auch heute live direkt
nach diesen Nachrichten um 19:30 Uhr auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen und in der
ZDF heute App
nach China wo gerade die deutsche
Außenministerin zu Gast ist höflich im
Ton aber in der Sache kompromisslos so
war der Tenor der Gespräche auf beiden
Seiten heute egal ob es um
Menschenrechte ging um Taiwan oder um
den russischen Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine eine Antwort des chinesischen
Außenministers ließ aufhorchen er
versicherte dass China keine Waffen an
Russland liefern werde Elisabeth Schmidt
berichtet
der chinesische Außenminister ist der
deutschen Außenministerin
entgegengekommen zumindest räumlich
chingang holt Annalena baerburg in
seiner Geburtsstadt hier in Gin ab dann
geht es per Schnellzug mit 320 km pro
Stunde nach Peking wo auch die
angespannten Beziehungen neue Fahrt
aufnehmen sollen es gibt vieles zu
besprechen Chinas Einfluss auf Russlands
Präsidenten Putin etwa
der Besuch von Präsident she in Moskau
hat gezeigt dass kein anderes Land mehr
Einfluss auf Russland hat als China aber
ich muss offen sagen dass ich mich frage
warum die chinesische Positionierung
bisher nicht die Aufforderung an den
Aggressor Russlands beinhaltet den Krieg
zu stoppen Chinas Außenminister bleibt
beim Thema Friedensverhandlungen weiter
unkonkret gibt aber ein Versprechen ab
bei Rüstungsexporten vertritt China eine
verantwortungsvolle Haltung wir werden
keine Waffen an Konfliktparteien liefern
es folgt ein Schlagabtausch höflich aber
deutlich Werbung ist im Vergleich zum
Kanzler der unangenehmere Gast in Peking
sie lässt keinen konflikthema aus
kritisiert Menschenrechtsverletzungen in
der Uiguren Provinz cindyang und warnt
vor einem Angriff Chinas auf Taiwan
eine militärische Eskalation in der
Straße von Taiwan durch die wirklich 50%
des Welthandels fließen wäre für die
gesamte Welt ein Horrorszenario
mit gegenseitigem Respekt aber keine
Lehrmeister aus dem Westen
am Nachmittag trifft bärbock nicht
Regierungsorganisationen und wird durch
einen Tempel geführt kleine Signale der
Verständigung am Ende des Besuchs
zumindest ein gemeinsames Fazit es war
gut zu reden vor allem auch beim Thema
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
fragen wir Andreas kühners der Annalena
baerbock nach China begleitet hat hat
die deutsche Außenministerin die
deutschen Interessen klug vertreten
ja sie hat sie zumindest sehr
kompromisslos vertreten so klar und so
forsch wie das bärburg seit Amtsantritt
versucht zu ihrem Markenzeichen zu
machen das haben hier im Peking und auch
in Berlin nicht alle klug gefunden vor
allem jene nicht die die sonst ja nicht
ganz so klaren Auftritte des
Bundeskanzlers zu schätzen wissen manche
sagen auch die diplomatischeren Aufträge
Auftritte denn jeder Klartext von
bärburg macht natürlich den typischen
spartext von Scholz deutlich und das ist
immer dann ein Problem wenn hinter dem
unterschiedlichen Ton auch
unterschiedliche Einschätzungen liegen
wie es ja in der china-strategie der
Bundesregierung der Fall ist und prompt
wird ja nun Werbung auch buchstäblich
jeden Tag aus der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
heraus kritisiert während ihrer Reise
und darüber wird nach Rückkehr bestimmt
noch zu reden sein
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung live
aus Peking Andreas Kühnast war das
während des Besuchs der Außenministerin
sind der bekannte bürgerrechtsanwalt
juven Cheng und seine Frau in Peking
festgenommen worden zwei weitere
Kollegen von ihm wurden unter Hausarrest
gestellt juwa auf dem Weg zu einem
Termin bei der EU-Delegation die direkt
neben der deutschen Botschaft liegt die
EU protestierte und forderte die
sofortige bedingungslose Freilassung der
Bürgerrechtler
er ist IT-Spezialist waffenar und in
einem niedrigen Rang bei der
US-Nationalgarde beschäftigt Jack t
wurde gestern festgenommen er soll über
Monate in einem Internetforum streng
geheime militärische Unterlagen
veröffentlicht haben offenbar um damit
zu prahlen jetzt Rätsel das ganze Land
wie es sein kann das so sensible
Verschluss Sachen in die Hände eines
21-Jährigen gelangen konnten wenn ihr
mir Daniel aus Washington
kommentarlos verlässt Jack Tees Familie
vor gut zwei Stunden das Gerichtsgebäude
in dem er dem Haftrichter vorgeführt
wurde gestern hatten FBI Beamte den
jungen Nationalgardisten in deiten
Massachusetts festgenommen er soll
hunderte Geheimdokumente in einer
chatgruppe gepostet haben ein
Gruppenmitglied äußerte sich will aber
anonym bleiben
sich als Anführer der Gruppe und war es
auch er wollte dass mir alle eine Art
von Supersoldaten sind und versuchte uns
zu formen mit Gottes glauben gut
bewaffnet und so weiter
ein Schrei nach Aufmerksamkeit sei wohl
der Grund für das Posten gewesen erzählt
das Mitglied der chatgruppe das solche
Dokumente für den erst 21-jährigen
überhaupt zugänglich waren können viele
Beobachter kaum glauben
das ist sehr gefährlich besonders wenn
man Geschichten wie diese hört dass
jemand so etwas liegt nur um sich zu
profilieren gerade junge Menschen
scheinen manchmal zu glauben dass so
etwas nur ein Spiel sein
das Pentagon hat den Zugang zu
Geheiminformationen bereits massiv
eingeschränkt wie sensible Daten künftig
besser geschützt werden können wird nun
intensiv geprüft
dazu gehören die Aktualisierung von
Verteilerlisten außerdem die Bewertung
wie geheime Dokumente weitergegeben
werden und eine Reihe anderer Maßnahmen
diese
Maßnahmen wird sich wohl auch der
US-Präsident genau anschauen Joe Biden
und sein Stab werden eine gute Strategie
erarbeiten müssen dass der Imageschaden
den das Militär und seine Regierung
bereits jetzt erlitten haben nicht noch
größer wird
Jack t wurde wegen der Entwendung und
Weitergabe von Geheiminformationen
angeklagt er wird sich wohl auf eine
lange Haftstrafe einstellen müssen
es ist ein Erfolg für Frankreichs
Präsident macron der oberste Hüter der
französischen Verfassung der
Verfassungsrat hat die hochumstrittene
Rentenreform weitestgehend gebilligt
seit Monaten laufen Demonstranten und
Gewerkschaften gegen die Reform Sturm
auch heute gingen wieder zahlreiche
Menschen auf die Straße Kernpunkt der
Pläne ist ein höheres
Renteneintrittsalter 64 statt 62 Jahre
mehrere Abgeordnete hatten den
Verfassungsrat angerufen damit er die
Reform überprüft seit einer Stunde ist
die Entscheidung bekannt eine Art in
Paris was bedeutet das grüne Licht des
Verfassungsrats
ja die Anspannung die war wirklich enorm
vor dieser Entscheidung und ich fürchte
sie wird sich auch gar nicht so schnell
legen hier in dem Gebäude hinter mir
haben die neuen Verfassungshüter die
Reform also gebilligt sie haben zwar
einzelne Artikel zurückgewiesen aber an
dem Kernelement nämlich die Erhöhung des
Renteneintrittsalters von 62 auf 64
Jahre daran gibt es keinen rütteln mehr
und macron kann sein großes Projekt nun
ganz offiziell verkünden es wird damit
gerechnet dass er das in den kommenden
48 Stunden tun wird aber Ruhe kehrt
damit noch nicht ein denn das der
Verfassungsrat hat noch eine zweite
Entscheidung getroffen er hat einen
Antrag der Linken Opposition abgelehnt
die hatten einen Referendum über den
Rentenbeginn gefordert und entsprechend
groß werden auch heute schon die
Proteste ausfallen viel hängt jetzt
davon ab wie die Regierung in den
kommenden Tagen kommunizieren wird wie
sie auftreten wird auch gegenüber den
Gegnern und für kommenden Dienstag hat
man erstmals wieder die Gewerkschaften
zu einem Gespräch eingeladen danke schön
nach Paris
Menschen ins All zu schicken ist
spektakulär die meisten Erkenntnisse
über unser Sonnensystem haben bisher
aber Sonden auf die Erde gefunkt heute
hat sich wieder eine auf den Weg gemacht
sie heißt juice und fliegt Richtung
Jupiter dem riesigen Gasplaneten mit dem
roten Fleck acht Jahre braucht die
europäische Sonde dorthin ihr Ziel nicht
der Jupiter selbst sondern drei seiner
Monde unter deren eiskrusten soll sich
flüssiges Wasser verbergen mehr von
dieser Welt
erfolgreicher Start der Ariane 5 auf dem
Weltraumbahnhof Kuru in französisch
Guayana sie bringt die Sonde juice ins
All gesteuert wird die Mission von hier
dem Kontrollzentrum der ESA in Darmstadt
45 Minuten nach dem Start sorgt dieser
kleine Ausschlag für Begeisterung ein
Signal von der Sonde wow wow
juice hat sich von der Rakete
abgekoppelt der nächste heikle Moment
das Ausklappen der großen Solarpaneele
die sind halt so groß dass man das auf
dem Boden auch nie testen konnte
man hat keine Halle die groß genug war
doch auch das hat gut geklappt nun
beginnt die achtjährige Reise der Sonde
zum Gasplaneten Jupiter und seinen
eismonten die Flugbahn ist kompliziert
es geht einmal um die Venus und dreimal
um die Erde um genug Schwung für das
weit entfernte Ziel zu bekommen die
Sonde muss Temperaturunterschiede von
-230
250 Grad aushalten ziel der Mission den
Jupitermond gar nie mit näher zu
untersuchen unter seiner Kilometer
dicken Eiskruste sollen sich riesige
Wasserschichten befinden ob die
Bedingungen für Leben gegeben sind ich
denke dass wir in den nächsten Jahren
dieser Frage auch dank der christmission
wesentlich näher kommen werden mit
Kosten von rund 1,6 Milliarden Euro ist
juice eine der größten und
spektakulärsten Missionen der ESA
jetzt nach Mannheim Mannheim hat sich ja
einige schöne Plätze zu bieten man muss
nur wissen wo von heute an hat die
300.000 Einwohner Stadt zwischen Rhein
und Neckar allerdings eine neue
Attraktion die man nicht lange suchen
muss die Bundesgartenschau sie will mehr
bieten als Pflanzenpracht und
freizeitkulisse ein Stück Zukunft Klima
Energie Stadt nahe Natur all das soll
mehr als zwei Millionen Besucher
anlocken Sven Klasse war da
viel passender kann der Willkommensgruß
für die ersten Besucher kaum sein Blumen
zum Start der Bundesgartenschau am
Morgen nach jahrelanger Planung sind die
ersten Gäste da und voller Vorfreude auf
alles das was es auf dem Gelände so zu
sehen gibt
Seilbahn Pinguine Kühe Tiere die super
Blumenbeete diese angelegt haben das
kulturelle Angebot aber auch mit der
Nachhaltigkeit also viele Themen kommen
irgendwie hier zusammen ich freue mich
jetzt schon seit vielen Jahren auf die
Burger und heute ist es endlich soweit
ja auch der Bundespräsident Schirmherr
der Bundesgartenschau ist gekommen im
Fokus dieser BUGA die Themen Energie
Nahrungssicherung Klima und Umwelt
entsprechend dazu das Geschenk dieser
Schulklasse sie haben Rücksicht genommen
die Jugendlichen
wenig Wasser braucht nachhaltig also und
auf diese Nachhaltigkeit wollten sie in
Mannheim auch beim Bau der BUGA achten
auf dem Gelände einer ehemaligen
amerikanischen Kaserne die nach dem
Abzug der amerikanischen Soldaten 2011
noch so aussah viel Beton Blech und
Steine bei dem Thema Stadtentwicklung
einmal das Thema Anpassung an den
Klimawandel und da Leiste die
Bundesgartenschau natürlich enorm ist
dadurch dass wir hier Böden entwickelt
haben dass wir eine Frischluft Schneise
geschaffen haben wovon Mannheim auch
nach der BUGA profitieren soll genauso
wie davon das große Teile des Geländes
als Naherholungsgebiet erhalten bleiben
du wirst hin hast du gerade gesagt aber
erst reden wir über Fußball Europa
League gestern Abend Leverkusen hat zu
Hause nur ein Unentschieden geschafft
gegen die Belgier aus aber die Jüngste
in der Bundesliga so erfolgreich wie
Bayern 11 wieder mit starkem Willen und
großen Kampfgeist der dann auch zum
verdienten eins zu eins Ausgleich führte
beim Rückspiel nächste Woche ist noch
alles drin
der 19 Jahre alte Nationalspieler
Florian Würtz bewahrt Leverkusen 8
Minuten vor dem Ende vor der Hinspiel
Niederlage gekonnt wie zielgerichtet er
den Ball zwischen allerlei Gegenspielern
auf den Weg bringt weniger gekonnt das
Leverkusen das Spiel zuvor das ist dem
bislang recht unbekannten Brüsseler
stadtteilclub erlaubt in Führung zu
gehen der Nigerianer Viktor bonifas
macht das 1:0 zu Beginn der zweiten
Hälfte Union Berlin hatten sie zuvor
schon aus dem Wettbewerb befördert die
Leverkusener sind gewarnt
morgen das Halbfinale im DFB-Pokal der
Frauen Liga Tabellenführer Bayern
München trifft auf die Verfolgerinnen
aus Wolfsburg ja und die müssen auf ihre
Topspielerin Alexandra Popp verzichten
und das ist ganz klar ein Nachteil für
die serienpokalsiegerinnen aus Wolfsburg
die am Nachmittag im Münchner Team Hotel
ankamen die verletzte Alexandra Popp
sozusagen die Allzweckwaffe der
Wolfsburgerinnen wird an allen Ecken und
Enten fehlen dazu kommt dass München
nach dem 1:0 Bundesliga Sieg vor drei
Wochen natürlich oben auf ist und neben
der Meisterschaft auch diesen Pokalsieg
will
wir haben diese Saison genossen und
wollen sie mit etwas glitzernden beenden
und die voll feiern dazu aber müssen sie
Samstag das Team schlagen das zuletzt
acht Mal nacheinander den Pokal gewonnen
hat
und deshalb viele Leute morgen live bei
uns im ZDF ab 13:40 Uhr bei der
Eishockey WM der Frauen in Kanada hat
das deutsche Team im Viertelfinale gegen
die USA mit 0:3 verloren trotzdem ein
großer turnierer Erfolg für die
db-frauen inklusive Klassenerhalt
doppeltes deutsches Achtelfinale aus
beim ATP-Turnier in Monaco Alexander es
wäre verlor gegen Daniel mit Videos und
Jan Lennart ruft gegen Andre
dafür hat das deutsche Doppel Kevin
Krawitz und Tim Pütz das Halbfinale
erreicht die beiden bezwangen den
Niederländer Jean Julia Roja und Marcelo
arribalo aus El Salvador souverän mit
6:2 und 64
weshalb Fingerspiel am Mittag und das
Ergebnis abends über uns wunderbar
vielen Dank zum Schluss noch ein Umzug
der besonderen Art von der Schweiz nach
Bayern insgesamt 8 Steinböcke die im
Kanton Wallis eingefangen wurden sollen
frisches Blut in die Wildnis südlich von
Bad Tölz bringen andernfalls droht die
Gefahr von Inzucht denn die 100 Tiere
die dort schon Leben stammen alle von
nur sechs Steinböcken ab ob die
neubewohner nach ihrer Traktorfahrt mit
einem frühlingshafteren Bayern gerechnet
hatten wissen wir nicht
ganz im Süden könnte es noch mehr Schnee
geben sonst hält sich der Regen am
Wochenende wo es trocken bleibt erzählt
gleich Christa Augen Dunja Hayali
begrüßt sie um 10 Uhr heute journal und
wir sagen danke und tschüss und bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen machen sie sich
ein schönes Wochenende
[Musik]
ja guten Abend die Zugbahn dieses
kleinen Tiefs hier führt es jetzt um die
östlichen Alpen herum und heute Nacht
und morgen zieht es dann von Osten her
in Richtung Deutschland das heißt es
regnet weiter und über das Wochenende
gibt es in den Alpen eine ordentliche
Portion Neuschnee heute Nacht regnet es
vor allem zwischen Schleswig-Holstein
und Ostbayern oberhalb von 900 Metern
fällt auch Schnee Nordosten lässt der
Regen nach aus Osten frisch der Wind auf
im Westen und Südwesten bleibt der
Himmel oft klar so dass die Nacht hier
kalt wird mit Werten bis zu minus zwei
Grad im Osten bleibt es milder mit fünf
bis acht Grad morgen erreichen wir meist
zwischen 10 und 16 Grad an der Mosel
aber unter den Regenbogen oder im
Südosten Deutschlands ist es mit 4 bis 9
Grad doch noch mal kühler und es regnet
eben weiter zwischen der Nordsee und dem
Alpenrand obwohl es von Norden her dann
schnell nachlässt von Tschechien her
auch da lässt der Regen etwas nach und
an der Ostsee und vor allem westlich des
Rheins sehen wir morgen auch einiges an
Sonne am meisten ist es dann im Nordstau
des Thüringer Waldes und der Alpen mit
um 15 Liter pro Quadratmeter und mit
Regen geht es auch in den nächsten Tagen
weiter von Norden her setzt sich dann
allerdings schon trockenes Wetter durch
das war es von uns tschüss